[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique du
week end les français pourront ils
partir en vacances ce sera le cas c'est
ce qu'a affirmé le premier ministre
cette semaine louis mais en france
seulement at il dit alors que l'italie a
décidé de son côté d'ouvrir ses
frontières au tourisme de 3 juin
prochain on a un peu de mal à s'y
retrouver des vacances méline france ou
pas c'est la question du débat ce soir
avec lydia guirous ce essayiste et
ancien membre du bureau politique les
républicains et georges kuzmanovic
fondateur de république souveraine
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france on va d'abord
écouté edouard philippe et on en débat
juste après s'agissant des vacances il a
encore sous réserve de l'évolution de
l'épidémie et de possibles restrictions
très localisées en fonction de son
évolution
nous privilégions une hypothèse
raisonnable
les français pourront partir en vacances
en france au mois de juillet et au mois
d'août
et quand je dis en france c'est
évidemment en métropole dans l'hexagone
et dans les outre-mer alors ça c'est
l'hypothèse raisonnable que l'on a
entendu
évidemment en début de semaine il dit à
guy roux ce depuis on a vu que les
plages ce sont des confiné que les mères
avaient pris des arrêtés pour cela est
ce que vous y voyez clair vous vous avez
déjà calé vos vacances bon résultat je
pense que comme beaucoup de français je
ne sais pas encore ce que je pourrais
faire cpt avait effectivement le premier
league a indiqué que nous pourrions en
des vacances en france dans les ados
d'écouté trotte dans les outre-mer alors
mais les compagnies aériennes donc pas
repris l'ensemble de leurs activités
j'entends que la frontière espagnole
italienne s'ouvre avec une condition
quarantaine pour l'espagne pour nous
acquitter quitter la france je ne sais
pas je pense que c'est le grand flou
effectivement quelques plages qui
s'ouvre notamment sur la côte atlantique
mais pour des activités sportives
donc je me dis qu'il va avoir beaucoup
de gens qui se mettre au sport nautique
pouvoir profiter de la plage je trouve
que ça na pas
bon dans les villes beaucoup de joggeurs
qui ont maintenant a disparu maintenant
que le continent je pense qu'il est
urgent de permettre aux français de
respirer après plus de deux mois
comptines et les français sont
responsables responsables de leur santé
ils savent aussi la face ils sont à
risque pas et et je peins qu'il faut les
laisser prendre au revoir leur vie et
voir choisir de partir en vacances monde
a besoin de plus de clarté de la part
des gouvernements on a souvent des
messages qui sont contradictoires s'est
très vite à gérer georges kiejman au
vide c'est votre sentiment est ce qu'il
n'ya pas encore du flou sur cette
question des vacances on sait que
l'union européenne a encouragé les les
27 à rouvrir leurs frontières mais la
france elle n'a toujours pas fait
d'annoncé en ce sens faut-il une réponse
coordonnée mais d'abord bonsoir je suis
d'accord avec ce que dit olivier gui gui
rousse le problème c'est que ce
gouvernement a fait tellement d'erreurs
certains disent de communication dont on
considère le gouvernement fait tellement
de couacs que même quand même s'il
disait quelque chose de conforme un peu
perdu un peu ce qui est bien
compréhensible
est-ce que ça va c'est le contraire
pourquoi me rappeler que ce gouvernement
a annoncé qu'il n'y avait pas de risque
de crise de contamination covic 19 et
puis après et s'est ravisé il n'y a pas
de prendre qu'il ne fallait pas utiliser
les masques que c'était vraiment pas
utiliser même dangereux qu'après qu'il
faut les utiliser donc bien évidemment
nous même ma famille comme celle de
dames qui rouge comme je pense à plupart
des français sont un peu dans
l'expectative et attendent pour choisir
leurs vacances
maintenant quant à votre seconde
question moi je suis très étonné de
cette
de toutes ces discussions c'est un
problème sanitaire
donc qu'ils devaient devrait gérer à
partir de d'éléments concrets sanitaires
et logistique
le problème n'est pas de bloquer la
france l'allemagne ou la belgique le
problème et éventuellement de mettre en
quarantaine des zones contaminées
s'il a ici par exemple imaginons une
zone contaminée autour du bas rhin et de
deux côtés de la frontière en allemagne
sa précence de mettre en quarantaine
cette zone là il pas de le faire par
pays mais de toute façon dans toute la
situation montre la complète des
connexions de cette union européenne que
tout ça jamais été envisagé et que on a
une union européenne qui n'est capable
de s'unir que pour punir les états qui
voudrait faire plus de dépenses
publiques
alors là en l'occurrence l'union
européenne et n'est absolument pas unis
là vous allez dans son dos ce qu'a
indiqué thierry breton cette semaine le
commissaire européen au marché intérieur
a dit effectivement une faudrait des
vacances oui mais par région ecoutez-le
il y aura une saison touristique cet été
évidemment elle va évidemment être
différente je vais pas dire par pis je
préfère dire par zone
on n'en prend pas le chemin les ja lire
ou 50 on voit que l'italie va rouvrir
sans même prendre des mesures de
quarantaine l'espagne qui a rouvert mais
qui maintient ses mesures de quarantaine
qui ces mesures qui vont être également
supprimés que faut-il faire concrètement
est-ce qu'il faut imposer ces mesures de
quarantaine par par pays moi je pense
que derrière les missiles de réouverture
des frontières de l'espagne et aussi à
des impératifs et économique
on sait qu'on va vers une oppressante
économique essaye de sauver en quelque
sorte la saison sauver ce qui peut
encore être entre être encore sauvée car
il ya des emplois derrière voilà les
italiens ont aussi le vent du tourisme
pour vivre pour soi la population
nous aussi nous avons des emplois sauvés
avec cette saison touristique à le
secteur de la restauration de
l'hôtellerie les campings qui vont
énormément souffrir et tant d'autres il
y aura un chômage qui sera très
important je pense saisonniers qui soit
ricker qui vont pas pouvoir faire ça
pour beaucoup leur saison comment il
faut se remettre au travail il faut
reprendre pour prendre ma vie je pense
qu'on peut mettre en quarantaine les
personnes qui sont peut-être les plus
exposés les plus fragiles il ya des
domaines scientifiques qui démontrent
que certaines tranches d'âge et moins du
vénérable coronavirus alors en a on a
des symptômes on souffre encore quinze
jours et on s'en sortent pas en
réanimation certains médecins commencent
à dire qu'on aurait pu ne pas continuer
de manière massive
maintenant c'est vrai maintenant on a
des masses qu'on s'est testé donc est ce
qu'il faudrait peut-être responsabilité
davantage les français plutôt que de
leur donner des restrictions il faut
cesser de parler aux français comme on
parle à des enfants il faut cesser de
jatte entendu l'une des petites phrases
de la santé il tribune est un petit peu
les bonbons on nous parle vraiment comme
si une protection des enfants et encore
une fois les français sont responsables
peuvent prendre en vain je pense qu à
des populations qui sont plus à risque
d'autres ces personnes là le sache s'il
vous des problèmes cardiaques ou autres
et se protégeront davantage que d'autres
on peut pas priver de liberté l'ensemble
de la population privée de vacances
l'ensemble de la population il faut que
la vie reprenne et que nous ne cédons
bien sûr nos libertés parce que l'on
celle d'aujourd'hui sera très difficile
à récupérer de ma en termes de libertés
la république donc je crois qu'il faut
qu' il faut qu'on crée ouvre les
restaurants avec des mesures sanitaires
évidemment pour permettre au secteur du
tourisme reprend aussi un coup moore une
respiration économique pour un pays où
si l'on ne fait pas ça et je crois que
c'est ce qui est aussi quitté la
décision italienne
beaucoup de gens vont souffrir les
ventes tombées dans une trempe précarité
et moi je veux absolument
on évite ces scénarios georges kiejman
oblige vous êtes d'accord est ce que
finalement maintenant l'économie ne
prime pas maintenant qu'on sait à peu
près appréhender ce virus on sait
appréhender on sait appréhender on verra
monsieur poète breton il bien sûr de lui
quand il dit
évidemment il ya une saison des vacances
on espère tous temps pour le bien-être
des français que pour sauver ce secteur
qui embauche millions de français et qui
une part importante de la richesse
nationale annuelle mais si la crise
n'aura pas de plus belle ça va devenir
très compliqué et puis il faut garder
une certaine logique
soit il n'y a pas de risque et sérieux
et dans ce cas là pourquoi ne pas aller
dans des pays voisins comme l'italie ou
l'espagne où ne pourraient pas venir
chez nous puisque eux mêmes ont été
confrontés à la même à la même crise et
ont appliqué les mêmes mesures
mais ça semble un peu étrange on peut
imaginer que le gouvernement veut
essayer de sauver par ce procédé là un
peu le tourisme en france même si ce
sera difficile
voilà c'est alors comment en france on a
on a 45 millions en 50 millions de
touristes potentiels de l'étranger nous
en vient 89 90 millions par an donc de
toute façon à moins de prendre le double
de vacances et que tout le monde aille
en vacances partout en france on va pas
réussir à compenser de toute façon il y
aura un choc
peut-être qu'on pourra parler après mais
c'est tout le débat
le vaste débat de la dette tant en
public que des entreprises ou que du
privé et je crois que le gouvernement
serait devrait particulièrement se
pencher sur cette question est comment
est ce qu'une partie de la dette privée
des entreprises pourraient effacer ou
reportés sur le rôle le plus long terme
car sinon ça va être une catastrophe
pour de nombreuses familles pour de
nombreuses petites entreprises
et là on va rester sur le sur le
tourisme un plan daide a été annoncée
aussi un soutien pour le secteur du
tourisme avait pour vous il n'est pas
suffisant compte tenu des pertes qui
s'annoncent il ne sera pas suffisant et
si d'aventuré ils n'étaient pas
suffisants espérons qu'il sera suffisant
mais face à semble peu probable s'il
n'était pas suffisant il faudrait
envisager de faire quelque chose sur
cette dette
d'ailleurs c'est une c'est tout à
l'heure il y avait une restauratrice
italienne qui s'exprimait que vous avez
interrogé lundi avec les salaires
continuent à payer avec les les
les loyers
avec les fournisseurs qu'on doit payer
pas on est en train d'accumuler une
dette colossale mais le gouvernement
doit se pencher sur cette bête là parce
qu'elle ne va pas être compensée même
par une saison touristique très moyenne
je voudrais qu'on écoute à présent
christophe castaner qui a réagi hier à
l'ouverture des frontières annoncées par
l'italie pour le 3 juin prochain
il est essentiel que nous puissions
avoir des décisions coordonnées au
niveau européen surtout sur l'infraction
gagnent mais ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et la décision unilatérale
de l'espagne cette semaine de l'italie a
annoncé ce matin ne conforte pas ce que
nous devons faire travailler ensemble en
solidarité
qu'est ce que ça montre de l'europe
lydia guirous sont la vue depuis le
début de cette crise là la réponse
européenne est difficile à coordonner en
tout cas en termes sanitaires en termes
d' aide en terme de relance économique
est là pour le tourisme c'est la même
chose c'est des pur sang de deux des
richesses de l'europe le touriste 1
l'europe s'est montrée extrêmement
décevante depuis de cette raison se
rappelle de l'épisode de madame
vanderlei noir un couple sur la façon de
se laver les mains ralentit pas là qu'on
attendait la façon dont ils vont laisser
tomber les italiens qui demandaient les
replis de respirateurs et mois
supplémentaires étaient donc comprends
qu'aujourd'hui les italiens ne pas
franchement envie de demander
l'autorisation à l'europe les ôter leurs
frontières et prendre leur destin en
quelque sorte en main le groupe s'est
montré décevant tant à ministre day de
l'europe dans ces crimes étaient
clairement le cahier il vient vos pizzas
quiches
ils ont entraîné un côté un seul des
technocrates européens qui n'ont pas su
rassurer ni à prendre les mesures qui
étaient suffisantes et je rebondisse
heureuse que des mannequins élite gp qui
marque le plan de relance pour le
tourisme je ne suis pas certaine que ce
sera suffisant c'est pour ça que l'on va
moindre neva à l'effet un catastrophique
qui va avoir sur le secteur du tourisme
de la restauration
c'est vrai qu'on appelle aussi les
français en tant que patrie
tease dans le choix de leurs vacances et
l'intrus qui partent en vacances en
france pour dépenser en france et
permettre à certains de deux de survivre
il ya énormément de petits chefs
d'entreprises des gens qui ont acquis
ont investi qui ont créé des emplois
aidés qui ils font en sorte raid
effectivement de se retrouve dans une
situation catastrophique et il y aura
énormément d'autres compilant ça va être
long des drames très important qu'on va
avoir c'est pas des go pas trop les
personnes qui se retrouvent ce dimanche
pour pouvoir créer leur emploi créé des
emplois pour d'autres qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans des situations très
compliquées
après l'étude des jaunes qui ont fait
quand même beaucoup de mal au secteur de
la restauration un secteur marchand
maintenant aussi la crise sanitaire qui
est ainsi l'une est dans une situation
dramatique et les plans ne sont pas
suffisants pour voir leur permettre de
s'en sortir donc on souvent français
partent en vacances en france je pense
vous êtes d'accord
vous êtes d'accord jusqu'à georges
kuzmanovic consommons français resteront
en france nous sommes en colocalisation
la réindustrialisation de ce pays et
pour qu'on produise plus dans ce pays et
dans ce contexte de crise grave de crise
économique encore plus grave qui a
commencé et qui va s'amplifier oui ce
serait bienvenu que de 2 pour ceux qui
le peuvent
d'aller en vacances quelque part à
quelque part en france sachant que fort
logiquement dans d'autres pays on
demandera les italiens dans mon droit
aux italiens de rester chez eux et et
ainsi de suite
ici on voulait réagir sur ce que vous
venez de dire mais c'est monsieur
giuseppe quand tu es le premier ministre
italien qui l'a dit il ya déjà quelques
semaines il a dit très claire alors que
c'est un fervent européen avant la crise
il a dit je nous nous en souviendrons
nous nous en souviendrons et de quoi il
fait que comme a dit l'un des gueules
aussi n'y aura pas d' aide
il n'y a pas eu d' aide
organiser les normes est non seulement
elle n'a pas une aide mais il ya eu des
sanctions de la cour européenne parce
que je ne sais quel règlement intérieur
de l'union européenne n'a pas été mis en
respecter mis en oeuvre par l'italie et
ils auront mis des amendes au moment où
il perdait des milliers des millions
d'un départ dans des milliers de leurs
concitoyens
donc on comprend bien que et puis vous
rajoutez à cela le fait qu' il n'y a
aucune volonté des pays du nord
mené par l'allemagne de d'organiser quoi
que ce soit au niveau européen je
parlais de la dette
et justement c'est une grande question
est l'idée de la dette des corona bond
était porté entre autres par l'italie eh
bien nous on a à nouveau cette allemagne
donc deux jambes deux bras le ski à
nouveau ne refuse la solidarité
internationale dans le cadre européen
ce dont nous étions sûrs nous sommes
pour pour sortir de cette union
européenne à parce qu'elle ne peut à
nation pas la seule d'arrêter elle l'a
montré qu'ils ont à l'avance alors
qu'ils profitent largement d'un euro qui
est totalement calibré pour l'industrie
allemande et refuse à l'avance une
solidarité aux pays qu'ils disent
méprisamment latin en l'occurrence
italie et bien je ne suis pas étonné que
les italiens disent écoutez mais nous on
reprend notre souveraineté on fait quand
on veut on a besoin d'ouvrir nos
frontières on ouvre nos frontières alors
on parlait de on parlait de vacances
made in france ou pas il y à la corse un
qui a décidé d'imposer un passeport
sanitaire si c'est possible ou pas on va
le voir écouter gilles simeoni le
président du conseil exécutif de corse
les semaines nous séparant de la date du
23 juin seront consacrés à la mise en
place de ce dispositif au plan médical
technique juridique et financier afin
d'avoir notamment des tests pcr qu'ovide
19 rapide et fiable et une application
permettant de s'en prévaloir
cela concernerait toutes les personnes
extérieures à la population résidente
corse de la diaspora et autres touristes
affinitaires touristes d'agrément et
touristes professionnels
alors on le voit certains pays ne
veulent plus avoir de mesures de
sanitaire des mesures d'isolement à
l'arrivée sur leur pays mais la corse
elle elle veut un passeport sanitaires
dont des régions qui sont pas très qui
voient d'un mauvais oeil aussi la flûte
certains touristes qui pourraient
provenir de zone rouge
lydia guirous ce qu'est ce que vous en
pensez écoutez moi je pense que la
france en france y est d'accord c'est
que la france est une république une et
indivisible que je ne vois pas pourquoi
la corse pourrait mettre en place un
passeport
ça me plaît parce qu'elle a été durement
touchée aussi un oui mais à d'autres
horizons qui ont été embauchés je pense
qu'on ne va pas mettre un passeport
sanitaires pour les gens qui viennent de
normandie france et d'autres régions
très rarement poussé touchés je trouve
ça un petit peu étonnant
je ne suis pas franchement favorable
même si je comprend des dispositions
pour protéger la population corse qui
les insulaires mais un pays en france on
a les mêmes règles pour tous ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut un titre qu'il faut
préserver et qu'il faut pas que ce que
l'on dit li la france et qui est des
vagues de différentes partout il
convoquerait espèce de baronnies lahoud
et c'est pas possible j'ai un départ
mais il a l'air de prendre ce genre de
décision aux collectivités selon vous à
moi je ne vois pas d'avoir un passeport
je crois pas que ce soit ce territoire
des points alors je crois qu'il faut
quand même qu'il a même règle partout et
par ce destin qui doit décider mais le
gouvernement en a aussi qui a manqué
d'autorité et qu'il a beaucoup hésité
donc ça c'est le champ libre à beaucoup
de textos à différentes on peut pas
avoir une leaf ou à le port du masque
est obligatoire
d'autres vivres ou c'est ce n'est pas
obligatoire il ya une rupture d'égalité
et et je crois qu'il faut faire très
attention à ça la règle partout la même
alors parfois on peut l'expliquer au
niveau des départements sur un
département rouge ou vert mais il
pourrait militer cette journée d
des règles différentes dans chaque ville
chaque sournois pour préserver
merci lydia guirous selon mot de la fin
pour vos george friedman au beach très
court vous êtes d'accord il faut des
règles partout qu'elle soit partout les
mêmes où c'est au maire de d'imposer
parfois des mesures un peu plus
drastiques en fonction de la situation
non mais dans l'absolu je suis bien
évidemment d'accord nous sommes une
république une indivisible
il faudrait remettre le une dans le
premier article de la constitution
mais ce gouvernement c'est ce
gouvernement qui a créé cette situation
dans bien des régions dans bien des
villes dans bien des entreprises et ce
sont les pouvoirs locaux qui ont dû se
débrouiller pour trouver des masques
donc ça ça vous met une certaine
défiance méfiance vis-à-vis du
gouvernement central que quand il prouve
son incapacité à agir sérieusement et
dans le cas de la corse
c'est bien évident je suis d'accord et
madame deros hurle sur le fond mais
c'est un cas particulier qui est bien
dans nuit vous savez très bien que la
corse est à une des régions de tourisme
massive ou vont beaucoup de franciliens
et de parisiens où il ya eu un énorme
foyer du comique 19 or les hôpitaux du
corps se sont un peu renforcé pendant la
période estivale mais ils ne sont pas
prêts du tout à supporter une une
pandémie
mais si les vagues massives avec
beaucoup de touristes sur le territoire
corse
merci beaucoup georges kiejman au vide
chez et merci à l'est via garros et
c'est la fin de ce débat merci d'y avoir
participé
merci à vous de votre fidélité rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]